[Música]
este instrumento que ustedes acabaron de
escuchar
se llama la marimba de chonta también
conocido como el piano de la selva el
día que lo conocí me interesó tanto que
decidí ir a investigar las costas del
pacífico sur de colombia
para ello decidir hasta guapi cauca dije
a buenaventura y allí me estaba
esperando un barco que se demora más o
menos entre 10 y 12 horas en llegar
el barco ya estaba flotando hacia mi
destino y llegué a descansar en la noche
a una cama baja del barco y alrededor de
una señora con su hija quizás de unos
ocho o diez años de edad y se acostó en
el piso igual que lo hubiese hecho
cualquiera de ustedes decidí mi cama
al no poder dormir entonces decidí ir
hacia la prueba del barco y no me
arrepiento porque me encontré con la
luna más hermosa que jamás había visto
blanca rebosante y además ella
deslizándose sobre las aguas del
pacífico estaba un rato y mirándola
cuando sentía que algo el lado izquierdo
me miraba y como unos 15 metros del
barco iba una burbuja
acompasada con las olas y además a la
velocidad del barco
y va subiendo y va subiendo y va
subiendo esa burbuja hasta que se llena
de luz de la luna y desapareció ante mis
ojos en la inmensidad del pacífico
colombiano
reflexionando sobre lo que había pasado
y pensando que era producto del
cansancio decidí ir a buscar cualquier
espacio del barco para recostar me un
rato cuando y bajando unas escaleras me
encontré con el cuerpo tirado en el piso
de la señora que unas horas antes le
había cedido mi cama
en ese momento pienso que quizás esa
burbuja era su alma su energía su
vibración despidiéndose por un acto tan
simple como el haberle cedido mi cama a
ella ya su hija para poder descansar
le brindó a ella los primeros auxilios y
alberto es que no respondía decidió
llamar al capitán del barco a los
marineros el auxiliar de enfermería y
ellos llegan rápidamente y el dictamen
es la señora ha fallecido
detrás mío sale su hija la niña gritando
mamá
se hace encima del cuerpo lo golpea lo
muerte lo besa inclusive se agrede a
ella misma la niña estaba en shock jamás
había visto tanto dolor en un cuerpo tan
pequeñito el capitán dio aviso a las
autoridades de guapi cuando llegamos a
las pocas horas la estaba esperando su
familia pero también un grupo de
cantadoras mujeres que aprendieron el
canto como una tradición de su cultura y
cuando alguien se muere en el pacifico
alguien mayor le cantan durante nueve
días para que su alma pueda pasar de
manera más armónica hacia el mensaje
según sus creencias
pero las cantadoras al ver que la niña
estaba tan afectada lo que hicieron fue
rodearla y le empezaron a cantar arroyos
que son canciones infantiles que se
cantaban los niños en el pacifico desde
que son bebés no había pasado un minuto
cuando la niña se reincorporó empezó a
cantar e incluso se le dibujó una
pequeña sonrisa en su cara y ahí me di
cuenta del poder transformador que tiene
la música que tienen estas mujeres en su
garganta y cambió mi visión
completamente como músico cuando regrese
a bogotá decidí hacer el primer festival
decantadoras del país que se hizo
ininterrumpidamente desde el año 2011
hasta el año 2017
encontrándome con procesos y voces tan
poderosas y milagrosas como
laden elimina tiene un episodio de dolor
profundo hace más de 30 años creó la
primera guardería afro de nuestra ciudad
taira quiñones le devolvió las tierras a
un puñado de campesinos quien desde un
ejercicio terapéutico desde el canto les
pudo volver sus tierras porque ellos
pudieron cantar y contar su historia
aurora ca ciegas liga en condición de
desplazamiento a bogotá a uno de los
barrios más complejos donde habitan y
coexisten todos los males de nuestra
sociedad hoy día atiende a más de 30
niños que a través de los cantos están
sanando y sabemos que están sanando
porque cuando ustedes los ven se les ha
devuelto su capacidad de soñar
el si valencia desplazada desde niña de
yesmín a choco haces imitar a santander
luego llega a bogotá o unos años después
como empleada doméstica y un día ella
estaba cantando frente al espejo con un
cepillo en la mano que hacía las veces
de micrófono y su empleadora la coge por
detrás y la tira al piso y como una
novela o una película le pone un pie en
su garganta le dice tú eres negra y no
naciste para cantar
naciste para limpiar
yo quiero decirles que canten para
ustedes mismos
canten lea su familia can tiene a sus
hijos canten a sus amigos nunca paren de
cantar
y quiero que además presencia en hoy el
poder sanador de la música y el poder
curativo que tiene el canto
por qué
porque me pega
porque me pegó
mamita
por qué
puede que
porque me puede al madre mía
[Música]
porque me llamó a mi todo
si yo a ti si yo a ti si yo a ti no te
yo nada hombre
un héroe
dónde
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
porque me pero como hábito
y con ese cuento tan duro
[Risas]
porque me pega madre mía
si bhatti te quiero tanto
w
que mi padre me
qué mejor que me pega mamita
si yo a ti si yo a ti si yo a ti
te quiero
tanto hombre porque me pega
[Aplausos]
[Música]
como comprender mejor este mágico y
maravilloso fenómeno de la música
cuando la música nos toca
se encadenan unos efectos
mecánicos
químicos y vivo eléctricos
en estructuras tan diversas de nuestro
cuerpo como el oído externo el oído
medio la membrana timpánica la cadena de
huesecillos
la ventana oval la cóclea el nervio
auditivo las áreas neuronales que
procesan toda la información musical en
todos sus aspectos lo rítmico lo
melódico la palabra cantada la corteza
frontal y en lo profundo del cerebro en
el sistema límbico la amígdala
y casi de manera automática el cerebro
toma esa información la interpreta y le
da un significado emocional
porque la música es ante todo un
lenguaje que comunica
como ustedes lo acaban de sentir
[Música]
podríamos hoy abordar múltiples
múltiples facetas
de cómo la música incide en el bienestar
y la salud humana podríamos hablar hoy
de cómo activa el músculo esquelético de
cómo incide en la función motora de cómo
podemos realizar regularizar la marcha
en los pacientes con enfermedad del
parkinson
o podríamos hablar de como rehabilitamos
a pacientes con lesiones de las
funciones del lenguaje en todas sus
dimensiones desde la palabra cantada
porque la función de la palabra cantada
se aloja en un área craneal distante
diferente de la palabra hablada
podríamos hablar de como en la
enfermedad de alzheimer
los bancos de memoria musical son los
últimos que se afectan
pero hoy vamos a tratar otro tema que
atañe a todos los seres humanos por
igual tengamos o no una de estas
patologías porque a todos
a niños jóvenes adultos y ancianos
a blancos y negros a hombres y mujeres y
a buenos y a malos nos toca el dolor
en su clasificación más general tenemos
el dolor físico y el dolor emocional ese
dolor físico que lo podemos ubicar y
cuantificar el dolor emocional no le
pregunte a la niña y cuánto te duele
hasta el infinito
voy a compartirles un registro de sesión
para contarles cómo y compartirles como
abordo el dolor emocional
llegaste a niño maravilloso destellante
y hermoso a mi sesión luego de
ausentarse tres meses había estado
conmigo prácticamente desde el vientre
porque su hermanita asistía
a la sesión
y su comportamiento irregular exacerbado
violento
del llanto a la risa del golpe
de pedir abrazo y después a agredirme me
alerta y al abordar a la madre me
comparte que está viviendo la pesadilla
y el horror del abuso sexual
me voy con el propósito
de componer una canción
para entregársela a ese niño como una
herramienta de vida
que le facilite el tránsito
por ese pasaje oscuro de la vida
así
nació el caracol
[Música]
ah
y yo soy el caracol félix caracol
voy despacio por la vida pollo vivo
lento y sin preocupación
siempre muy tranquilo porque sé que todo
tiene solución el caracol
muy bien
después de la lluvia sale el sol declaró
después del frío siempre viene el calor
vive tranquilo como el caracol y yo que
siempre pasan todo el día de corte que
aprendió bien que en función de falta a
tendrás un señor creció y lloras mañana
a reinar
[Música]
aprende a esperar
como el caracol que espero día mejor
[Música]
cómo
porque siempre pasa el color
solos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
dos días después de que decantara en la
sesión cuatro veces la canción este niño
la mamá me llama de compartir
juan paulo es increíble lo que sucedió
en esa sesión
viéndose obligada a cumplir el acuerdo
legal tiene que llevar al niño a la
visita dominical con el posible agresor
deja al niño y diez minutos después el
niño la llama
ven por mí por favor no me dejes aquí no
quiero estar aquí ven por mí por favor
y esa mamá siempre fuerte ante sus hijos
los recoge y se derrumba en llanto
y el niño le dice más a mí
no llores no te preocupes acuérdate de
la canción del caracol
y todo tiene solución
[Música]
atrás de esta historia
profundamente emotiva
subyace allí la explicación de cuál es
la mecánica a través de la cual la
música incide profundamente en las
emociones humanas
porque la sesión está construida y
diseñada de manera tal que propiciemos
las condiciones perfectas ideales para
que en el niño surja de manera
espontánea
el insight
el punto mágico de comprensión profunda
el clic el on
a través de una terapia tradicional
pueden tardar años y ese momento no
llega
pero la música tiene la capacidad de
viajar directamente a lo más profundo
del cerebro
y activar las funciones emocionales de
la amígdala conectarse inmediatamente
con las áreas más modernas de la corteza
prefrontal y prefrontal y
suceder en el momento mágico y ese
momento mágico es lo que permite que el
niño tome para sí una herramienta y la
aplique en su vida
minimizando
el trauma en el episodio doloroso
y permitiendo que
sale más pronto y lo procese más pronto
esto en el dolor emocional
y el dolor físico
cuál es la mecánica que subyace allí
para que la música llegue a disminuir
hasta en un 70% la sensación dolorosa
fue mi hermana el último día de su
muerte que me dijo
la morfina no me quita el dolor solo
deja de importarme que me duela
canta
sí
[Música]
[Risas]
y es que la felicidad tiene forma de
acordeón
el hecho irrefutable de que el sentido
de la evolución humana es el oído
porque no olfateamos como el oso ni
vemos cómo el águila ni en la noche como
el gato
el oído que permitió la evolución humana
fue lo que permitió la evolución humana
ese vídeo del público cantando
no lo demuestra
una flauta de hueso hallado a entre
40.000 y 80 mil millones de años está
afinada exactamente en esas melodías que
cantaba el público
el input sonoro y el estímulo sonoro
viaja por el sistema nervioso
privilegiando la escucha claro viaja
llega al tronco cerebral
y en su interior en la formación
reticular
hay 90 nódulos de terminaciones
nerviosas 1 en especial que se llaman
locus coeruleus
que se encarga de las reacciones
fisiológicas entre otras es la central
de alarmas del cuerpo que alerta sobre
todo lo que sucede y toda esa
información periférica llega allí
el estímulo sonoro llega y de allí se
conecta con la razón con la memoria con
la emoción e inunda mos todo el sistema
con el sonido de la música
y su traducción emocional y su
significado emocional y de esta manera y
vivimos el avance del input doloroso
y de paso
evitamos la reacción fisiológica
el dolor es común a todos el dolor del
alma o el dolor de la marginación o el
dolor de la discriminación el dolor de
la guerra o el dolor de la pobreza
el dolor del duelo el de la lesión
o el dolor de la enfermedad
la música medicina para el dolor y ahora
yo les pregunto
quién
quien no tiene una espina en su vida
quien no tiene una espina encima
[Música]
y me cuerpo espina
dime
[Música]
la mención
tanta espinal vida
la espina
con otras descanso con feliz
con tanta vida en tu vida
sí
con bases para ser campeón
pregúntele a leer y suelo soñadores
permisos
pregúntele al ente soñador si yo le
aprendí
[Música]
de dicho soñador
para que voy a vivir soñando siempre
pensando
como es
para ti
espiritual
[Música]
todos
y
y tú
para pactar copas
por eso vive soñando un niño vive
siempre soñando
[Música]
[Aplausos]